[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العنوي
تجدد الاشتباكات في الخرطوم وام درمان
والجيش يكثف غاراته على مواقع الدعم
السريع
مجلس التعاون الخارجي يشدد على اهميه
مشاركته بالمفاوضات النوويه مع ايران
ويدعو للتصدي لكل ما يهدد الملاحه البحريه
الدفاع الروسيه تعلن التصدي لهجمات
اوكرانيه والجيش الاوكراني يعلن استعاده
قريه في جنوب البلاد
وسلطات المصريه تعلن فقدان ثلاثه سائحين
بريطانيين بعد اشتعال النيران في قاربهم
في البحر الاحمر
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه ما
كانت تنتهي هدنه الاربعه والعشرين ساعه في
السودان حتى عاد صوت الرصاص والقذائف الى
ما كان عليه فقد تجددت الاشتباكات العنيفه
بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
العاصمه الخرطوم
وتمحورت بحسب مراسل العربيه في وسط وغرب
الخرطوم وفي ام درمان مشيرا الى استخدام
اسلحه ثقيله وخفيفه خلال الاشتباكات في
محيط جسر الحلفايه في مدينه بحري شمالي
الخرطوم حيث توالت الانباء عن سيطره الجيش
عليه
وقد اكد مراسل العربيه سماع عدوي مدافع
ثقيله وتصاعد السنه اللهب والدخان وتحليقا
للطيران الحربي منذ ساعات الصباح مؤكدا ان
طيران الجيش قصف تمركزات لقوات الدعم
السريع في مدن الخرطوم
المتحدثه الاقليميه بسم اللجنه الدوليه
للصليب الاحمر كانت قد ذكرت ان فرق
الحمايه التابعه للجنه في السودان تستقبل
اتصالات دائمه للابلاغ عن حالات فقدان
لافراد من العائلات السودانيه منذ بدء
الصراع قبل حوالي شهرين
وبحسب المتحدثه لم تتوقف البلاغات حتى
الان مع مرور كل يوم مع استمرار عمليات
البحث عن المفقودين المبلغ عنهم
وشددت ايضا على ان عمليه التقصدونها عوائق
عديده ابرزها الاقتتال المستمر وشح
الامكانيات والموارد الطبيه حيث تعيق
عمليات التعرف على الجثمين او انتشارها
اذهب الى اقليم دارفور ينضم الي من هناك
الصحفي صالح ابو علامه صالح اهلا وسهلا بك
جديد الاشتباكات والمواجهات واين تركزت في
الساعات القليله الماضيه
حتى هذه الساعات يشهد هدوء ولا تجدد
للاشتباكات بحسب ما يرد الينا من مدن
الاقليم
المتفرغه لكن الوضع الانساني في غرفور
ماذا لا كما هو لم يتحسن في
مناطق دارفور مدينه الفاشر تشهد نزوح كبير
قادم من محليه كتم التي شهدت قتال بين
الجيش والدعم السريع خلال الايام الماضيه
وسيطر على هذه المدينه الدعم السريع كما
في بيانه ايضا هنالك ولايه غربي دارفور
مدينه الجنينه الاتصالات مقطوعه تماما عن
مدينه الجنينه ما زال الوضع الانساني كما
هو لم يتحسن لا تستطيع فرق الانغاز او
المنظمات الدخول الى مدينه الجنينه نسبه
لما تشهده الطرق من عمليات التفلت وعمليات
نهب وعمليات قتال مستمر في محيط مدينه
الجنينه والطرق المؤدي اليها وحتى داخل
مدينه الجنينه نزوح كبير ولجوء كبير جدا
كما ذكرت النزوح من الفاشر باتجاه اي يعني
النازحون عندما ينزحون سواء من الفاشر
ايضا من الجنينه الى اي مناطق وهل هذه
المناطق التي ينزحون اليها هي مناطق امنه
نعم هو النزوح من الفاشر يعني كان من
الاحياء
الغير امنه الى الاحياء الامنه مستمر حتى
هذه اللحظه بالمدارس وبمواقع كثيره في
مدينه الفاشر يعني اضافه الى هذا النزوح
هنالك نزوح من محليه كتم التي
نزحوا الى داخل مدينه الفاشر هنالك لجان
لواء نازحين من مدينه الفاشر داخل المدارس
وداخل الاماكن العامه في مدينه الفاجر حتى
هذه اللحظه هنالك ايضا نزوح حول مدينه كتم
نعلم بان الاحداث التي دارت في مدينه قطن
تاثر بها كثيرا معسكر يسمى كساب هو يتبع
للنازحين في الفتره الماضيه فروا الى
القرى المجاوره والى مواقع كثيره مجاوره
لمحليه كتب بغرض الاحتماء بالمناطق الامنه
حتى
هل من يتابع اوضاع هؤلاء هل هم متركون
لحالهم لمصيرهم ام لا فمت منظمات او
جمعيات تتابع احوالهم خصوصا في مرحله
نزوحهم
نعم معظم معظم الانشطه هنا في دارفور هي
فقط انشطه اهليه مجتمعيه شبابيه تطوعيه
تدخل لتحسين الاوضاع الانسانيه وتدخل ايضا
لاجلال جرحه وتدخل ايضا لمعالجه بعض
القضايا الانسانيه لا يوجد منظمات ابدا
حتى هذه اللحظه هنالك يعني حركه لكن هذه
الحركه حتى الان نسبه للتفلتات الكبيره
ونسبه لحاله السيوله الامنيه في دارفور لا
تستطيع المنظمات حمايه ابدا
اطقمها والذين يعملون معها خلال هذه
الفتره هنالك فقط حراك اهلي حراك مجتمعي
شبابي لهذه
الاحداث ساكتفي بهذا القدر من اقليم
دارفور الصحفي صالح ابو علامه شكرا جزيلا
لك صالح على كل هذه المتابعه
الى اندرمان الان ينضم الي الصحفي المقداد
حسن مقداد اهلا وسهلا بك جديد للشباكات
والمواجهات سواء في ام درمان او في
الخرطوم بحري واين تركز تحديدا في الساعات
الماضيه خصوصا جسر الحلفايه والكلام انه
الجيش تمكن من السيطره تماما على هذه
النقطه
تحياتي اليك طالب والى المجاهدين نعم
الاشتباكات منذ الصباح الباكر وحتى هذه
اللحظه نحن نستمع الى الطائرات الحربيه
تحلق في سماء العاصمه المثلثه بمدنها
الثلاث وكذلك الطيران الاستطلاع نستمع
ايضا الى دوري المضادات الارضيه التي تتبع
لقوات الدعم السريع باتجاه هذه المقاتلات
الحربيه التي تتبع للجيش السوداني هذه
المقاتلات قصفت صباح هذا اليوم مناطق
متفرقه في العاصمه الخرطوم ابتداء من وسط
العاصمه الخرطوم ومركزها حيث شارع الغابه
والمنطقه الصناعيه وهذه المنطقه كما
تابعنا في الايام الماضيه انها تتواجد
فيها قوات الدعم السريع ايضا القصف امتد
حتى شرق النيل بمدينه بحري في تلك المنطقه
ايضا تتواجد قوات الدعم السريع بكثافه
وجنوبا في مدينه ام درمان هذا القصف ايضا
طال مناطق الصالحه التي هي تتبع لها قوات
الدعم السريع باعتبار ان هنالك معسكر
لقوات الدعم السريع في تلك المنطقه ايضا
كان القصف المدفعي من تمركزات الجيش
السوداني بشمال مدينه ام درمان يستهدف
مناطق متفرقه ايضا كما ذكرت ان جسر
الحلفايه من الجسور الاستراتيجيه دارت فيه
اشتباكات عنيفه صباح هذا اليوم وتابعنا
كثير من الفيديوهات التي بثها النشطون
وايضا تحدثنا الى مصادر عسكريه تحدثت عن
سيطرت قوات الجيش السوداني على ذلك الجزء
الان وفي هذه اللحظه استمع الى طائره
حربيه مقاتله تحلق في سماء مدينه ام درمان
ربما هي الان بصدد تنفيذ غاره جويه على
على بعض المناطق الاستراتيجيه في مدينه ام
درمان هذا القصف ايضا الذي يعني ابتدى
صباح هذا اليوم راح ضحيته مدنيون في جنوب
الحزام او ما يعرف بمناطق الازهري جراء
القصف الذي يقع عشوائيا على منازل
المواطنين باعتبار ان هذه الاشتباكات تكون
وسط احيانا تكون وسط احياء بها
بغداد هل سجل يعني
وضعنا موضوع جسر الحلفايه جانبا هل سجل اي
تقدم نوعي لطرف على طرف اخر في الساعات
ال24 الماضيه ام لا ستاتيكو ما زال قائما
يعني لا يعني لم يتقدم اي فريق على اخر او
اي طرف على اخر
نعم حتى هذه اللحظه ربما هو الصوت الاعلى
للمقاتلات وللاشتباكات ولم يعني تسجل اي
جهه رسميه بيانات صادره من الجيش السوداني
او من الدعم السريع بتقدمها في منطقه او
تاخرها في اخرى وبالتالي نحن ننتظر ان
تصدر هذه البيانات ونحاول ان نتواصل مع
القيادات العسكريه في عما اذا كانت تقدم
الجيش السوداني او تقدم الدعم السريع في
منطقه هنالك فيديوهات بثها ناشطون وتحدثنا
الى ما صادر عسكريه تتحدث عن ان الجيش
السوداني وصل من شمال مدينه بحري حتى شارع
المدينه حتى شارع المعونه جنوبا جنوب
مدينه مدينه بحري وهذا الشارع هو ربما من
الشوارع التي شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه في
الايام الاولى وسيطرت عليه قوات الدعم
السريع والان المصادر العسكريه تحدث الينا
ان هنالك تقدم للجيش السوداني في هذا
الشارع بمدينه بحري لكن بالمقابل قوات
الدعم السريع ما تزال تنشر فيديوهات عبر
صفحتها الرسميه بانها يعني استحولت على
على مركبات تتبع للجيش السوداني انها
سيطرت على عده مناطق دخلت اليها قوات
الجيش السوداني صباح هذا اليوم وبالتالي
نحن ايضا هنا في حرب بيانات اعلاميه وحرب
اعلام يحتاج الى توضيح بالنسبه للجهتين
لكن على العموم الجيش السوداني منذ صباح
هذا اليوم كثف غاراته وكثف هجومه بصوره
واضحه وكبيره جدا في رقعه جغرافيه واسعه
من العاصمه الخرطوم في شرقها وغربها
ووسطها وفي مدينه ام درمان ومدينه بحري
منهم درمان الصحفي المقداد حسن شكرا جزيلا
لك مقداد على كل هذه المتابعه من داخل
مستودع الغاز
كان
والمحروقات
في المستودعات
شرق الكلاكله من داخل المستودعات
غاز بالجمله نهي بسرقه كل حاجه كل حاجه
المستودعات فاتحه بنزين جاز راس الله يكون
في عونك يا شعبي الله يكون في عونك يا
شعبي
قاعدين في نص الدعامه والناس دي كلها على
روقه ماخذين راحته مكاتب المستودعات
وكاتب المستودعات
لحاله المستودعات من الداخل
حال المستودعات
التعامل الخليجيه على اهميه التزام ايران
بعدم تجاوز نسبه تخصيب اليورانيوم
للاستخدامات السلميه وضروره التعاون
الكامل مع وكاله الطاقه الذريه كما اكد
المجلس في بيان الله على ضروره مشاركه دول
الخليج في جميع المفاوضات بخصوص برنامج
ايران النووي وان تشمل المباحثات كافه
القضايا والشواغل الامنيه لدول المجلس
وشدد كذلك على ضروره الحفاظ على الامن
البحري والممرات المائيه في المنطقه
والتصدي لكل ما يهدد خطوط الملاحه البحريه
والتجاره الدوليه والمنشات النفطيه في دول
المجلس
وادانا المجلس اقتحام مقار بعثات
دبلوماسيه لدول المجلس في السودان مؤكدا
ضروره احترام الاتفاقيات الدوليه والاعراف
الدبلوماسيه
على صعيد اخر شدد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو على ان تل ابيب لن تكون
ملزمه باي تسويه سيتم التوصل اليها بين
واشنطن وطهران
وستتخذ كل الاجراءات اللازمه لحمايه امنها
حسب تعميرها
يوم الخميس الماضي تحدثت مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه واكدت على موقفنا الثابت العوده
الى الاتفاق النووي مع ايران لن توقف
برنامج الطيران النوويه بل ستسمح لايران
فقط بتوجيه الاموال بمبالغ كبيره الى
اذرعها في المنطقه وحول حدود اسرائيل شددت
على ان اي اتفاق مع ايران لن يلزم اسرائيل
مع او بدون اتفاق سنواصل القيام بكل ما هو
ضروري لحمايه اراضينا
الى ذلك قال المرشد الايراني الاعلى عليخ
منه ان الغرب لن يتمكن من منع ايران من
تطوير اسلحه اذا اراد الطهران ذلك واضاف
ان بلاده ستستمر في العمل والتعاون مع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه بشرط
احترام القطاع النووي الايراني
يجب عدم المساس بالبنيه التحتيه للصناعه
النوويه خلال هذه السنوات قام المديرون
والمسؤولون والناشطون في هذه الصناعه
باعمال مهمه وانشاوا بنيه تحتيه كبيره قد
ترغبون في عقد اتفاقيات في بعض المجالات
النوويه لا توجد مشكله اتفقوا لكن لا
ينبغي المساس بالبنت تحتيه ولا ينبغي ان
تتضرر يجب احترامها فهذه هي نتائج جهود
الاخرين
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
محادثات تونسيه اوروبيه لمكافحه الهجره
غير الشرعيه وعرض بتقديم مساعدات لتونس
بنحو 900 مليون يورو
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
التصدي لهجوم الاوكراني بسته زوارق مسيره
على سفينه تابعه لاصول البحر الاسود
بالقرب من خطي انابيب يقعان على بعد 300
كم من القرن وذكرت الوزاره ان قواتها
تمكنت من تدمير الزوارق السته واشارت الى
ان طائره مسيره تابعه لسلاح الجو الامريكي
قامت بعمليه استطلاع اثناء الهجوم
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت ايضا التصدي
لثلاث هجمات شنتها قوات اوكرانيه في محور
زابروجيا ونشرت مقطعا مصورا يظهر استهداف
دبابه اوكرانيه بصاروخ موجه اطلق من الجو
ياتي هذا فيما يقول مسؤولون موالون لروسيا
انهم سجلوا مئته هجوم بمسيارات قرب محطه
خلال الشهر الماضي
على شاشات التلفزيون الحكومي وهو يمنح
وسام النجم الذهبي لبطل روسيا وهو اعلى
وسام عسكري روسي لهؤلاء الجند
[موسيقى]
وش الاوكراني اعلن انه استعاد قريه بجنوب
البلاد في اول مكسب لهجومه المضاد الرئيس
الاوكراني
كان قد اعلن بدء قوات كييف الهجوم المضاده
على روسيا ويرى محللون عسكريون ان تحديات
كبيره تواجه كييف لضمان نجاحه هجومها منها
تامين الدعم الجوي وانهاء الهجوم قبل موسم
الامطار الذي يبدا في غضون خمسه اشهر
لم توقف هذه الفيضانات التي اجتاحت جنوب
شرقي اوكرانيا جراء انهيار سد نوفا لم
توقف القتال المستعر فيها حتى انه تصاعد
في شرقها تزامنا مع بدء الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه تقول ان
المعارك العنيفه مستمره على جبهه القتال
مع تاكيدهم ان كيف تمتلك المبادره وزير
الدفاع الروسي سيرجي شايغو بين ان قوات
بلاده صدت هجوما اوكرانيا ليلا جنوبيه
شارك فيه 1500 جندي اضافه الى 150 عربه
مدرعه مع محاولات اوكرانيه لاختراق الخطوط
الروسيه
المعارك استمرت ايضا حول فيليكا نوفو
سيلكا التابعه لدوناتك الواقعه شرقا
ويعتقد محللون ان المنطقه ستشكلان خط
المواجهه المستقبلي
اما باخموت التي شهدت واحده من اطول
المعارك واكثرها دمويه في الحرب فان
القوات الاوكرانيه تتقدم فيها ضد نظيرتها
الروسيه
تطورات عسكريه ترسم خط الهجوم المضاد
الاوكراني الا ان محللين يربطون نجاحه
بتوفير طائرات مقاتله قادره على توفير
الدعم الجوي
وبانهاءه خلال خمسه اشهر قبل بدء موسم
الامطار الخريفيه التي تجعل الارض
المفتوحه غير سالكه للمركبات المدرعه
الثقيله ويقاس نجاح الهجوم المضاد بالتمكن
القوات الاوكرانيه من اختراق الخطوط
الروسيه على طول الطريق الى بحر ازوف فاي
قوات روسيه غربيه لاختراق ستكون اكثر عرضه
للخطر وكل ما سيبقى بعد ذلك هو تدمير جسر
القرم الذي يعتقد ان روسيا ستعتمد عليه
لخطوط الامداد ومن ثم مهاجمه السفن
والطائرات المستخدمه لعرقله الامدادات الى
شبه الجزيره
سيناريو ان حدث سيونهي الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه بحسب محللين الا انه لن يحدث
برايهم في القريب العاجل رش خياط العربيه
لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل ينضم الي من
موسكو الان المحلل العسكري الروسي
اهلا وسهلا بك الغرب تحديدا بريطانيا ما
زال يعتقد ان الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد
سيحقق اهدافه وان كيف تمتلك زمام المبادره
ما رايك بهذا الكلام
تحدثنا عن المبادره فهي دائما تكلفه
الحياه والمعدات ولكن لا يمكن انتصاره
بالحرب من خلال الدفاع فقط
فالقوات الاوكرانيه تحاول ان تخترق الخطوط
الروسيه
هم يضربونها في مناطق
متفرقه ولكن الى الان روسيا نجحت في
احتواء الهجوم الاوكراني ولكن هم سيستمرون
لانهم ليس لديهم اي خيار اخر اقصد
اوكرانيين وسوف يحاولون ختاما اختراق هذه
الخطوط وتعديل خططهم
واستراتيجياتهم من اجل
مواجهه المقاومه الروسيه
الاوكرانيون على الارجح كانت لديهم خطه
لاختراق الخطوط الروسيه لم تنجح
لان الخطط العسكريه حتى افضلها
يلقى بها في القمامه حاله ما تواجه العدو
على ارض المعركه
فيبدو بان المعركه ستكون طويله ودمويه
خلال الصيف وكلا الجانبين سيحاول ان
يتكيفت مع وضع الطرف الاخر في هذه المعركه
الحاسمه التي ستدوم الى ما لا يقل عن شهر
اكتوبر طيب ولكن السيد فاضل
الى اعتبار الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد بانه
فشل او فاشل وهل يمكن الحكم منذ الان على
فشل او نجاح هذا الهجوم ام هذا كلام غير
منطقي ابدا على الاقل في العلم العسكري
القياده الروسيه والجيش الروسي بلا شك
يرغبون بان يقولوا بانهم منتصرون حققوا
النجاح هذا مهم جدا لمعنوياتي المقاتلين
وربما حتى اهم لمعنوياتي الشعب الروسي
والذي لم يشهدوا الكثير من نجاحات
العسكريه في هذه الحمله الطويله الدمويه
فانعم هم يقولون بنا الاوكرانيين فشلوا
وتكبدوا الخسائر
لكن الطرفين بداء الخسائر وهكذا هي طبيعه
الحرب ولا يزال الوقت مبكرا لان نقول
اوكرانيا او هجومها قد حزم او فشله وهذه
نهايه القصه فهي ليست كذلك كلا الجانبين
بكل ما لديهما الى هذه المعركه لتحقيق
النجاح
سؤال الاخير و باختصار وزير الدفاع سرقه
شوي جو كرم اليوم الجنود الروس الذين
تمكنوا من اصطياد دبابات ليوبارد ومدرعات
برادي الامريكيه هنا السؤال هل تحولت هذه
الحرب الى حرب لاثبات ذات الاسلحه الروسيه
في مواجهه الاسلحه الغربيه
للقول انه هذه الاسلحه الروسيه تتفوق
تماما على الاسلحه الغربيه
اي حربه وكاله خلال الحرب البارده مثلا تي
فيتنام حيث قدم الامريكيون اسلحتهم
الجديده
هنالك اسلحه غربيه تواجه اسلحه روسيه وكل
طرف
يحاول ارسال اسلحه متقدمه في كل يوم اللي
يتخلص من اسلحه الطرف الاخر هكذا هي طبيعه
مثل حروب الوكاله هذه
وستكون مزيده من الاسلحه الغربيه وروسيا
بالمقابل ستحاول مجابهتها من موسكو المحلل
شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
اعلنت السلطه التي تقودها قوات قصد في
شمال شرق سوريا اعلنت ان الفي اجنبي من
مقاتلي تنظيم داعش المحتجزين في سجون في
المنطقه سيحاكمون بعد ان رفضت بلدانهم
الاصليه استعادتهم قصد جددت مطالبتها
انشاء محكمه دوليه لمحاكمه هؤلاء
المقاتلين من حوالي من حوالي 60 جنسيه كما
دعت الامم المتحده وجماعات حقوق الانسان
الدوليه الى المساعده في تسهيل المحاكمه
وتحتجز قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه المدعومه
من الولايات المتحده التي يقودها الاكراد
اكثر من عشره الاف من مقاتلي داعش الاسرى
في حوالي 20 مركز احتجاز
لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا الموضوع ينضم
الي من اربيل الباحث السياسي رستم محمود
اهلا وسهلا بك لماذا لم تستجب الدول التي
ينتمي اليها هؤلاء المقاتلون لطلبات
استردادهم ما هي الحجه وهل ثمت مخطط يراد
من ورائه ابقاء هؤلاء في هذه المنطقه ربما
لمشاريع اخرى
يعني تجوزا لاشكاليه ان هؤلاء اسرى او
ليسوا اسرى لا اعتقد ان مصطلح اسرى يطلق
عليهم هؤلاء مجرمون ارتكبوا اعمال اجراميه
بحق البنيه المدنيه وارتكبوا مجازر جماعيه
وعمليات جينوسايت هائله جدا هؤلاء ليسوا
جزء من اي جيش نظامي حتى يعتبروا اسرى
الموضوع الاخر لماذا ترفض الدول استقبالهم
لثلاثه اسباب مركبه يعاني منها تعاني منها
الاداره الذاتيه في شمال شرق سوريا وقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه منذ قرابه عشره سنوات
وحتى الان السبب الاول هو استجابه للطلبات
التركيه والايرانيه الى حد بعيد وطبعا
النظام السوري لان اي استجابه واي تعامل
مع الاداره الذاتيه بشكل رسمي يعتبر
اعترافا بها وهذه الدول تمتنع عن ذلك
الشكل من التعامل مخاوف خوفا او او
استجابه لمحاذير تركيا من الاعتراف بتلك
الاداره المساله الاخرى ان هذه لو استعادت
هؤلاء الارهابيين فانها لا تملك اي ادله
جنائيه على ارض الواقع لتقديمهم الى
المحاكمات مجموع مسرح الجريمه التي
ارتكبوا فيها هذه الجرائم كانت منطقه شمال
وشرق سوريا حيث يوجدون وتريد هذه الدول
ضمنيا من ان يتم محاكمتهم هناك لان جميع
عناصر الجريمه موجوده في تلك المنطقه
الشهود والارتكابات
والضحايا والى ما الى ذلك المساله الثالثه
البنيه القانونيه في تلك الدول مسترخيه
الى حد كبير ولا تخاف من ان يستغل هؤلاء
الارهابيين هذه البنيه القانونيه الرخوه
التي يستطيعون عبرها وعبر منظمات حقوقيه
ان ان ينفوا فيها انتمائهم الى تنظيم داعش
او ان يجمدوا المزيد من العناصر ضمن بنيه
السجون التي لا يمكن يعني سجنا حتى لو
كانوا بمستوى ارهابي عالي جدا بشكل
انفرادي هذه الاسباب جميعها ترفض تدفع هذه
الدول لان تمتنع عن اجراء اي محاكمه دوليه
على ارض شمال شرق سوريا او استعاده هؤلاء
الارهابيين طيب استاذ رستم بس بقاء هؤلاء
في الشمال السوري حتى وان بقوا في السجون
او صدرت بحكهم بحقهم احكام بالسجن الا يعد
ذلك قنبله موقوته وكبيره جدا قد تنفجر في
اي لحظه يعني عم نتحدث نحن عن نحو 2000
مقاتل
بالضبط هو الامر كذلك ولاجل ذلك هو موضوع
تراجيدي تماما يعني الاداره الذاتيه في
شمال شرق سوريا تعتبر نفسها جزءا من
الحداثه الانسانيه من طرف لا تطبق عقوبه
الاعدام استجابه تامه للمعايير
والاتفاقيات الدوليه ومن طرف اخر لا تريد
ان تنشئ اي محكمه شكليه كما تفعل الانظمه
الديكتاتوريه التي تحاكم يعني امثال هؤلاء
الارهابيين خلال دقائق وتعدمهم هيا تريد
ان تطبق جميع المعايير العالميه ان يكون
هناك شهود وان يكون هناك دفاعيا كان هؤلاء
المدافعون وان يكون هناك حقوق كامله
لهؤلاء لان يدافعوا عن انفسهم وفي المحصله
لن تطبق عليهم حكم الاعدام يعني هناك
مجرمون ثم مئات الشهادات بحقهم وثمه
اعترافات بحقهم لكنهم يعني يتمتعون بجميع
الحقوق الانسانيه للمعتقلين العسكريين
الموجودين في اي منطقه لكنهم في المحصله
ليسوا فقط خطرا على الامن القومي لسكان
تلك المنطقه وقد حدث ذلك
يستضيف الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد زعماء
ايطاليا وهولندا والاتحاد الاوروبي لاجراء
محادثات تهدف الى تمهيد الطريق لخطه انقاذ
اقتصادي دوليه واعاده الاستقرار لبلد اصبح
مصدرا رئيسيا للمهاجرين الى اوروبا
هذا وقد شددت رئيسه الوزراء الايطاليه
جورجيا ميلوني على ان تونس او لويه
بالنسبه لايطاليا وان اي زعزعه للاستقرار
فيها سيكون له تداعيات خطيره على استقرار
منطقه شمال افريقيا باكملها وان التداعيات
ستصل ايضا الى ايطاليا
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل اعلنت من
جهتها ان الاتحاد الاوروبي مستعد لتقديم
مساعدات ماليه لتونس تقدر بنحو 900 مليون
يورو الى جانب تقديم 150 مليون يورو
اضافيه للدعم في مواجهه ازمتها الحاليه
نحن مستعدون لتقديم مساعدات ماليه لتونس
تبلغ نحو 900 مليون يورو بالاضافه الى
تقديم 150 مليون يورو اضافيه لدعم تونس في
ازمتها الحاليه الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتبر
الشريك التجاريه الاكبر لتونس ونحن نسمح
لزياده هذه الشراكه التجاريه وتقويتها
لزياده فرص الوظائف في البلاد
وتعتبر تونس نقطه عبور رئيسيه لمن يسعون
الى الهجره خاصه الافارقه من منطقه
افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
تونس كانت واحده من الدول القليله التي
ابرمت اتفاقيات لاعاده توطين لاعاده توطين
مع ايطاليا وبالتالي ليس لدى التونسيين
الذين يدخلون ايطاليا بشكل غير قانوني اي
اسباب لتقديم طلبات اللجوء وتتم اعادتهم
وتاتي زياره الزعماء الاوروبيين الى تونس
بعد ايام من توصل دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
لاتفاق بشان خطه لتقاسم المسؤوليه حول
المهاجرين الذين يدخلون اوروبا بطريقه غير
قانونيه وهو السبب الاساسي لواحده من اطول
الازمات السياسيه داخل الاتحاد
معي من تونس لمزيد من المتابعه الاعلاميه
والمحلل السياسي خليل الرقيق استاذ خليل
اهلا وسهلا بك الى نشره الخامسه هل
المعادله اهلا هل المعادله الاوروبيه باتت
واضحه وبسيطه وعلى الشكل التالي ايها
التونسيون احرسوا لنا حدودنا من المهاجرين
والطالبي اللجوء والا لا وجود لاي مساعدات
هل المعادله على الشكل التالي لا اكثر ولا
اقل
في الحقيقه المعادله ابتعدت كثيرا عن هذا
الشكل خاصه وان الموقف التونسي كان مسبقا
في ذلك تونس لن تكون حارسا لاحد بل ستكون
متعاونه مع الجميع على قاعده العداله على
قاعده عدم الاستعلاء في معالجه القضايا
ذات الصله بالهجره غير النظاميه مع ان لا
تكون تونس في في هذا كل في كل هذا محرومه
من سيادتها ومن تقرير مصيرها فقط لا غير
حكايه حراسه الحدود اليوم وقفنا امس مع
زياره الرئيس لصفاقس وقد قال هذا حتى وزير
الخارجيه الايطالي اصبحت تونس تتحمل ما لا
يمكن تحمله من تدفقات هجره من افريقيا
جنوب الصحراء وهذه التدفقات اصبحت تستقر
في البلاد معه امكانيات متواضعه في
مجهودات الانقاذ مع امكانيات متواضعه في
الاعاشه نظرا لما تعيشه تونس في حد ذاتها
من اشكالات في التزود بالمواد الغذائيه
والمواد الاساسيه اليوم استطيع ان اقول ان
مؤشرا ايجابيا جاء من الاوروبي ولا اقول
العكس ما معنى مؤشر ايجابي اليوم اوروبا
قد اقتنعت ربما بعد مجهود ايطالي كبير
وهذا يذكر يعني بشكل واضح قد اقتنعت انه
لا يمكن مساعده تونس وفق المشروطيه التي
رسمتها الاسره الدوليه المانحه يعني صندوق
النقد الدولي لا يمكن اعانه تونس مع يعني
رفع الدعم عن المواد الاساسيه مع بيع
المؤسسات العموميه اذا هناك برنامج للدعم
سيكون على قاعده غير ايديولوجيه اي علاقه
تبادل المنافع وتقاسم التضحيه
انت ادرى انت ادرى يعني لا يوجد شيء
بالمجان خصوصا من قبل الدول الاوروبيه
ماذا تملك تونس من خيارات من اوراق للقول
الاوروبيين لا يعني انا مني حارس عند
الحدود في حين ان يعني
الاوروبيين يريدون يعني بالدرجه الاولى
يعني وقف موجات الهجره واللجوء من السواحل
التونسيه ماذا تملك من اوراق ضغط تونس وهي
نحن نعرف انها بامس الحاجه الى المساعدات
الاقتصاديه والماليه من الدول الاوروبيه
الحاجه ايضا الى تامين حدوده وبامس الحاجه
الى ان لا تكون مشكله الهجره السريه عبئا
عليها لوحدها هذه مساله وليس فيها اي شيء
يعني هناك اتفاقات دوليه الفعل الهجره غير
النظاميه مجره من قانونا لكن كيف نتصدى له
تملك تونس مقترحات كبيره اقنعت بها حتى
الاسره الاوروبيه نفسها يعني
اقتنعت بمقترح رئيس الجمهوريه ان تتجاوز
المساله المقاربات الامنيه وان تدخل
اوروبا في حوار جديد مع افريقيا عبده عبر
مؤتمر الدولي لمعالجه اشكاليه الهجره غير
النظاميه خارج المقاربه الامنيه اي
بمعالجه الاسباب الجذريه للهجره السريه
هذا نجده هذه القناعه نجدها مجسده في
الخطاب الرسمي
وزير الخارجيه يتحدث فعلا عن وجوب ان
تنخرط اوروبا والاسره الدوليه المعنيه
بملف الهجره في مقاربه لتشجيع يعني
المواطنين الافارقه على البقاء في بلد
المنشا والمقترحات تتمثل في وجود مشاريع
تنمويه حقيقيه افريقيا شعوب فقيره بدول
غنيه تسخر بالطاقات كيف نوظف هذه الطاقات
في اطار تشجيع على الاستقرار في افريقيا
وفي تونس وكيف تتحول العلاقه من علاقه
استعلائيه الى علاقه التعاون بمعنى ايجاد
مشاريع تنمويه التكوينيه هذا ايضا نجده في
مذكره التفاهم التي وقعت بين الحكومتين
التونسيه والايطاليه والتي لم تعد تقتصر
على حارس الحدود بل اصبحت تتحدث عن دعم
قطاعات ذات اولويه كالصحه والتعليم
والتكوين بغرض التشغيل في اوروبا بالهجره
النظيفه النظاميه اذا هناك تطور في
الحقيقه السلطات الايطاليه اليوم ليست
سلطات الايطاليه بالامس اليوم الدولي ليس
الوضع بالامس بمعنى هناك ضروره لان تدخل
اوروبا مع افريقيا في حوار مغاير اي كيف
تستفيد افريقيا من التنميه حتى تستفيد
اوروبا
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من تونس الاعلامي
والمحلي السياسي خليل الرفيق شكرا جزيلا
لك على هذه المشاه شكرا
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
عاصفه رمليه قويه تضرب مدينه الموصل
العراقيه وتؤدي الى تدني للرؤيا
قالت السلطات المصريه ان ثلاثه مواطنين
بريطانيين فقدوا بعد ان اشتعلت النيران في
قارب غطس لهم كانوا على متن قباله الساحل
على البحر الاحمر كما قالت محافظه البحر
الاحمر ان اثني عشر من افراد الطاقم واثني
عشر سائحا بريطانيا تم انقاذهم عندما
اشتعلت النيران في المركب قباله مدينه
مرسى علم جنوب البحر الاحمر وقالت عقب
الفحص الاولي للسفينه ان ماسا كهربائيا في
غرفه محرك القارب ادى الى اندلاع النيران
واكدت ان عمليات البحث عن السائحين
البريطانيين الثلاثه ما زالت
جاريه
معي من الغردقه لمزيد من المتابعه مراسله
العربيه ندى حجازي ندى اهلا وسهلا بك هل
توضحت ملابسات هذا الحريق وما هو مصير
السائحين البريطانيين الثلاثه هل عرف
اهلا بك يعني لازال لسه ما فيش صوره واضحه
يعني
لمكان السائحين المفقودين هو المرجح او
يعني المتوقع ان هم يكونوا لسه في السفينه
الغارقه هي طبعا ابتعدت عن مكان الحريق 20
كيلومتر ولا زال البحث عنهم مستمر في
السفينه الغارقه
والناجين يعني دلوقتي موجودين في مرسى
السياحي
لتلقي الراحه
والعلاج اللازم بس هما يعني كويسين وطبعا
الفحص المبدئي للمركب بيقول انه كان بسبب
ماسك كهربائي في غرفه المحركات طيب ندى
اكثر من حادثه في الايام الاخيره بالقرب
من السواحل المصريه يعني حادثه القرش الذي
هاجمت سائحا روسيا
وقضى نحبه الان حادث
اشتعال هذا المركب وثلاث سائحين مفقودين
بالطبع لا يمكن الربط بين هذين الحادثتين
او بين هذه الحوادث ولكن تاثير ذلك على
قطاع السياحه على المشهد السياحي في مصر
ونحن نعرف ان قطاع السياحه في مصر يضر
جزءا لا يساهم به على الخزينه المصريه
اكيد طبعا بس يعني النهارده انا في وجودي
في الغردقه
الشواطئ بدات تفتح نوعا ماابس طبعا في
تحذير ان احنا في حد معين ما ينفعش حد
يعديه في السباحه انا شايفه ان الاقبال
والله لا يعني كبير او معقول في العادي في
الطبيعي طبعا ده مش وقت الزروه في السياحه
في البحر الاحمر في مصر يعني
مش مش وقت زوره لكن ده المعدل الطبيعي
عادي جدا الدنيا كويسه ما فيش ما فيش خوف
او هلع اكبر من اللازم لانه ده حدث عربي
نادر مش بيحصل في مصر كتير اما بالنسبه
للحريق فبرده هي يعني مش مش حاجه
بتتكرر يعني ده مقصرش قوي على الرحلات
اللي طالعه ولكن اكيد في نفس الوقت هو في
في حاله من من الزعر من من الموقف نفسه
ومن ان في ثلاث اشخاص احنا دلوقتي مش
عارفين هم فين طب هل زادت السلطات المصريه
من اجراءات السلامه بعد هذه الحوادث يعني
خلال متابعتك شفتي انه لا في اجراءات اكثر
يعني تشدد على مستوى السلامه العامه على
الشواطئ ام لا يعني الامور ما زالت على
حالها ندى
لا في اجراءات كتير جدا للحفاظ على سلامه
كل السياح وكل زائري مدن البحر الاحمر
خصوصا بعد حادثه القرش كمان وفي كمان
اجراءاته ومحاولات للبحث في ان الفنادق
تحط شباك في في البحار المفتوحه علشان
كمان الاسماك دي ما تقدرش ان هي تقرب من
الناس اللي بتسبح لحد معين وعلشان ما
يتكررش طبعا حادث زي ده مع طبعا ان في طول
الوقت ناس على الشواطئ بتحذر وبتتابع
بتابع كل بينزل وبيتنوه لو حد راح ابعد
لحد ما الاجراء بهذا القدر من الغردقه
مراسله العربي ندى حجازي شكرا جزيلا لكن
نادى على هذه المتابعه
تسببت امطار غزيره عقبتها رياح شديده في
مقتل 27 شخصا على الاقل بينهم ثمانيه
اطفال في شمال غرب باكستان
وقال متحدثون باسمي سلطه اداره الكوارث
اما العواصف ضربت اربع مقاطعات في اقليم
خيبر وتم اعلان حاله الطوارئ وشاهدت
باكستان امطارا الموسميه غير مسبوقه في
الصيف الماضي غمرت اكثر من ثلث البلاد
بالمياه والحقت اضرارا بمليونين منزل
وتسببت بمقتل اكثر من
1700 شخص
ضربت عاصفه رمليه قويه مدينه الموصل
الشماليه العراق ما ادى الى تدني للرؤيا
واجتاحت العاصفه ابرز المباني والمعالم
المحليه في الموصل فيما سجل العراق رقما
غير مسبوق في عدد العواصف الرمليه العام
الماضي بلغ اكثر من اثنتي عشره عاصفه
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات